After the emotionally draining epic that was
Avengers: Endgame, Spider-Man: Far From Home
swung into theaters to offer some sweet relief
to the legions of Marvel fans looking for
a superhero fix with slightly smaller stakes.
Far From Home delivered all the heart, thrills,
and goofiness we've come to expect since Tom
Holland took over the spandex in 2016's Captain
America: Civil War.
But there are a lot of little touches in Far
From Home you probably missed.
A mighty Earth Elemental wreaks some serious
havoc in Mexico during the cold opening of
Far From Home, so we don't blame you if didn't
catch the super-nerdy clue the filmmakers
briefly put on screen to herald its arrival.
A license plate with only "463" visible appears
briefly near Nick Fury and Maria Hill when
the Elemental pops up.
This is likely a nod to Amazing Spider-Man
#4 from September 1963, the issue that introduced
the world to the Earth-based villain Sandman.
Sound like a stretch?
Well, Marvel already snuck a few license-plate-based
Easter eggs into the Far From Home trailers
that didn't make the theatrical cut of the
film.
Before the water Elemental attack is teased
in the first "Official Teaser Trailer" from
January 2019, for example, there was a boat
in the background with "ASM 212" on the side.
It's almost certainly a reference to Amazing
Spider-Man #212, the issue that introduced
Spidey's "wet threat": Hydro-Man.
Flash Thompson even tells his classmates about
a guy who got water powers named "Morris Bench"
that he read about on the Internet another
clear reference to the comic book alter-ego
of Hydro-Man.
But that's not all!
In a London-based clip seen in the "Official
Trailer" from May 2019, a car with the license
plate "2865 SEP" appears.
This probably refers to Amazing Spider-Man
#28 from September 1965, which marked the
debut of the fire villain Molten Man.
This particular UK plate was cut from the
final film, but a similar plate number pops
up in Prague in the theatrical cut: ASM 28965,
for Issue #28, September 1965.
There's also at least one other license-plate
based Easter egg in Far From Home that has
nothing to do with the Elementals: MTU 83779,
spotted on Nick Fury's license plate in Berlin.
It may look like just another random string
of letters and numbers, but we're guessing
it's a reference to Marvel Team-Up #83 from
July 1979, which featured a team-up between
Spider-Man and Fury.
The story of MTU #83 begins, or so the text
tells us, with a "murdered" Spider-Man on
a Manhattan rooftop.
But wait!
He awakens and begins to remember the events
of the night before, which culminated in Nick
Fury shooting Spider-Man and a woman who appeared
to be Black Widow with an "anaesthetic bullet."
In other words, he used non-lethal ammo that
appeared real.
So, like in the events of the Berlin sequence
of Far From Home, MTU #83 features Fury seemingly
at odds with our friendly neighborhood Spider-Man.
In Far From Home, fake Nick Fury is an illusion
used to trick (and incapacitate) Spider-Man.
In MTU #83, Nick Fury's fake bullets are an
illusion used to trick (and incapacitate)
Spider-Man.
Neat!
The rest of the plot of MTU #83, which involves
Silver Samurai and the teleportation ring
he obtained from Saturday Night Live's John
Belushi, is probably irrelevant.
It does, however, feature a seemingly dead
Black Widow appearing alive and well in a
S.H.I.E.L.D.
lab, but we're not even touching that one.
To test his newfound powers in his 1962 Amazing
Fantasy #15 debut, Peter Parker takes on a
musclebound wrestler named Crusher Hogan,
who promises $100 to anyone who can stay in
the ring with him for three minutes.
Our Spider-Man-in-the-making, of course, easily
bests Hogan, and variations on this origin
story have popped up several times since.
"Kick his spider ass!
Yeah!"
After Aunt May's "Homeless Support" fundraiser
in Far From Home, if you look closely behind
Happy, you'll see a Crusher Hogan poster with
that same $100 offer.
There's also a ring bell nearby, so it looks
like this building is where Crusher made the
offer.
We never got to see the MCU's Peter Parker
take Crusher down, but this poster is a decent
consolation prize, and confirmation that MCU
Spidey likely had a similar origin story as
his comics counterpart.
Benjamin Franklin Parker, aka orphan Peter's
father figure "Uncle Ben," has yet to appear
in the MCU, but his memory looms large.
In the original Amazing Fantasy #15 origin
story, Uncle Ben is killed by an unnamed burglar
the same burglar Peter could have apprehended
following a TV appearance, had he not been
so caught up in his newfound fame.
Peter later tracks the burglar to a warehouse,
where he captures him and leaves him for the
police to deal with.
Peter realizes in the final panel, famously,
that "with great power there must also come
great responsibility!"
Spider-Man: Homecoming writer John Francis
Daley told Entertainment Weekly in 2017 that
Uncle Ben was almost referenced directly in
the MCU, but plans changed.
"It was when [Peter] was getting ready for
homecoming and the wardrobe [Aunt May] was
giving Peter was all Uncle Ben’s clothes.
It was a nice moment, but we also knew that
it veered away from his arc.
If you’re going to talk about someone’s
death, you don’t want it to be a throwaway."
In Far From Home, it's revealed that Peter
is using Ben's old luggage, but the connection
goes unmentioned on screen.
If you look closely, the monogram "BFP" is
featured on the suitcase in the scene in which
Peter is packing for his summer vacation.
Blink and you'll miss it, but the giant novelty
check Happy Hogan carries into the back room
after the "Homeless Support" fundraiser in
Far From Home is signed by Pepper Potts.
Potts is listed here as the co-founder and
chair of the "Stark Relief Foundation," which
probably sounds familiar if you've rewatched
Avengers: Age of Ultron recently.
"Stark Relief Foundation?"
"Already on the scene."
In Age of Ultron, Tony Stark asks Maria Hill
about The Stark Relief Foundation following
the so-called "Duel of Johannesburg," in which
a spellbound Hulk and a Hulkbuster-suited
Tony Stark caused massive collateral damage
to South Africa's largest city.
The foundation's purpose, it appears, is to
provide aid to populations impacted by the
messy work the Avengers have historically
engaged in.
In Far From Home, viewers can assume that
Pepper has donated such a large sum to help
the homeless population of Queens recovering
after "the blip."
The brief-but-welcome return of Daily Bugle
head honcho J. Jonah Jameson, played once
again by J.K. Simmons, is one of the many
highlights of Far From Home, coming during
the mid-credits sequence which appears to
set up the next MCU Spider-Man flick.
Simmons played the cantankerous journalist
in Sam Raimi's Spider-Man trilogy, but Far
From Home's incarnation is a little bit different.
"He must have given up.
Thrown in the towel.
Abandoned his sad little masquerade!"
In Far From Home, Jameson is more unstable
than ever, and his desire to smear Spider-Man
is cranked up to 11.
Befitting of the times, the Daily Bugle now
appears to be an online conspiracy-mongering
tabloid news program, clearly styled to resemble
The O'Reilly Factor, or even the MCU's version
of InfoWars.
This darker take on Jameson then outs Spider-Man
as Peter Parker, leading Parker, in Far From
Home's final line, to echo the final interrupted
line of Homecoming, uttered by Aunt May when
she discovers Peter's secret:
"What the f — "
Considering that ex-Stark Industries scientist-turned-Mysterio
lackey William Ginter Riva preserved Mysterio's
high-tech handiwork for later use, meaning
even more crazily realistic illusions could
be on the way in Far From Home's follow-up,
having a paranoid conspiracy-monger like Jonah
eager to smear a now-outed Peter Parker is
a recipe for disaster.
WTF, indeed.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.